[MUSIC PLAYING]
To Get Fit with Jodelle podcast, I am, as usual, Jodelle.
And I value and respect Dr. Peat as he has generously
come back on the podcast.
And every time I get to talk to you, Dr. Peat,
I'm like a kid in the candy store.
I just can't wait to see what kind of nuggets of goodness
you're going to teach me today and teach our listeners too.
So thank you so much for coming back on.
Well, I really want to pick your brain on the topic
that everybody's thoughts are on today.
Obviously, COVID-19 is what everybody's kind of focused on
right now.
And then I've got some listener questions as well.
So I hope we have time to get to those too.
So if you're ready, let's begin, OK?
All right.
All right, so let's first hear your thoughts
on coronavirus, this novel strain of it.
What are your thoughts on this?
I've been looking for any information I can get on it.
I've run across several well-known, prominent,
influential virologists who the media are totally ignoring.
But they have information on the internet that you can find.
And I was wondering what evidence is there
that it's such a dangerous strain,
because there haven't been any published numbers that
made it look like anything out of the ordinary.
For example, in the United States, from all causes,
the total annual death rate is, I think,
2,700,000, 2,800,000, something like that,
approaching 3 million per year dying,
which if you think of the population as more than 300
million, that's less than 1%.
And since we don't live 100 years on average,
that means that the population is skewed towards old people.
It's bent towards young people, away from old people.
So the longevity looks artificially long,
like we're averaging more than 100 years lifespan.
But despite this odd population, you look
at the number of people dying in any four-month period
about the length of a typical flu season.
That comes out to about 900,000 deaths from all causes
in a period of four months.
And in a typical year, the average dying from flu
is less than 10% of all causes.
The highest year, according to the CDC,
was in 2017 to '18, with more than 60,000 people dying
of flu-like infections.
And historically, any year that they
looked for the components of those flu-like infections,
about half of the people with influenza or symptoms
like that, half of them no pathogen has been identified.
But the most common pathogens are
the respiratory syncytial virus and the common cold rhinovirus.
And previously, the coronavirus, which
is about 10% of those people with flu infections,
whereas rhinovirus, I think, is about 30% of the flu infections.
And so historically, lots of people
are dying from flu, apparently caused by rhinovirus,
common cold virus.
And the coronavirus, historically,
has been considered a major cause of the common cold.
So it has been considered just a mild, almost harmless virus.
But the proportion of the flu infections
caused by coronavirus varies from 5% to 15%.
So if you look at an average being around 10%
of the, say, 60,000 flu deaths per year,
that means an ordinary annual death
from coronavirus-related flu in the United States
would be from 4,000 to 6,000 people, just an ordinary year.
And so far, we're towards the end of the usual flu season.
Yesterday, I think, was 1,100 deaths in the United States.
So we're way below a normal death rate
from coronavirus-related flu.
So I can't see what the excitement is.
I'm so glad to hear you say that,
because why is no one talking about the fact that every year,
1.25 million people die from traffic accidents?
More people die in a year from texting and driving,
probably, or just traffic accidents in general,
than there are people dying from colds and flus.
Yeah, and gunshot deaths in the United States
ranked right up with traffic accidents, 35,000.
So in your opinion, then, do you personally
think there is any conspiracy theories that
are worth entertaining with regard to this pandemic,
or no?
Oh, definitely, since I can't see any rational justification,
the most rational thing, I watched the Democrat primary
debate between Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders.
And you could see that they were rushing
to be prepared by calling for extreme crisis measures
against the flu while Trump was saying, it's nothing special.
Don't get excited.
They were hoping that there would be enough of a panic
that they could get credit for being more panic-promoting
than their opposition.
So it looked like politicians were in competition
to see who could be most panicked.
For many years, I've been following the progress
of germ warfare research.
And just in 2015, in Nature Magazine,
one of the world's biggest science magazines,
there was a news story about the creation
of pathogenic coronaviruses at the National
Laboratory at Fort Detrick under the sponsorship of CDC.
And the editors just a few weeks ago inserted a note right
under the title of that news item saying,
this is recently being cited as a possible source
of the corona flu epidemic.
And the editors were saying, I don't believe that.
But the fact is, the news was reporting
that the researchers for the government
were developing pathogenic varieties
for the purpose of creating a vaccine ahead
of the appearance of a similar pathogen in nature.
And then last summer, the CDC closed down that lab
because they were not taking proper precautions
against the escape of pathogens into the environment.
So an accidental release seems like a very likely explanation
for this particular pathogen.
Except immediately, government-connected
virologists rushed into print explaining
why it would be impossible for the lab
to have created this particular pathogen.
I think my personal experience with that lab--
I was teaching a course in 1969, or maybe early '70.
I had taken some courses in virus-related molecular
biology, supposedly the latest stuff.
And at that time, the HIV surface antigens
that are involved in the infectivity of the HIV virus
had not been published.
That came out in '71.
But a person came that didn't sign up for my course,
but he stayed for the first class.
And after everyone left, he stayed
and said that basically he just wanted to talk to someone.
He had recently quit his job at the Fort Detrick lab,
he said, because he ethically felt it was something he
didn't want to be connected with.
He said they were working on the design of an ethnic
or racially specific virus.
And since that didn't seem plausible in terms
of the coursework that I was currently taking,
I didn't know how seriously to take him.
But he seemed very depressed and didn't
know what to do with his life, because he thought people
should know about what he thought was a very dangerous policy
going on.
Anyway, just a couple years later,
papers were published by people at that lab
showing that there were antigens on the surface of white blood
cells that would make it possible for a virus
to be racially selective.
Wow, I didn't even think about that.
That's unbelievable.
What are your thoughts on the fact
that the governments around the world
are also rolling out 5G technology at this time?
At the same time that coronavirus is a pandemic,
there's a lot of cities rolling out 5G.
I don't know if you are familiar with that
or if you've read much about that.
Do you think there's any correlation with that?
I've been following the effects of electromagnetic radiation
since I think it was in 1956.
My brother was in the Navy.
And he described someone on his ship
who had stood in front of the radar too long.
And his brain was basically cooked by the radar.
And that led to research showing that a monkey
with a small brain doesn't have any brain damage.
But if the wavelength is similar to the diameter
of a human brain, that frequency will damage that organ,
that there is a resonance in a microwave which
is similar to radar.
Certain substances will heat much faster than others.
That's because of a resonance of the molecule.
But there's also a resonance of organs
according to the size of their chamber.
The spleen is enclosed in a membrane.
The brain is surrounded by membranes.
And it electrically forms a kind of analogous to an antenna
that resonates to particular wavelengths.
And just hearing those stories in the 1950s about what radar
does got me interested in paying attention over the years
to what the cell phones are doing with the wavelength.
Some of them analogous to the diameter of the gonads,
or the brain, for example, or the eyeball.
And it's now known that cell phones
do terrific damage to the gonads if they're
carried in a pocket, for example, of the pants.
Yeah, and I had read something that
was talking about the symptoms of COVID-19
are very similar to the symptoms that people
have felt with exposure to 5G technology,
such as one of the initial symptoms being loss of smell.
Both of those are correlated together.
So I just found that interesting.
And I wanted to see if you knew any correlation with that
at all.
I've been studying the inflammatory system for a long
time.
And in recent years, I've been paying attention
to the angiotensin system, which used
to be thought of as exclusively a matter of blood pressure
regulation.
And for many years, there have been drugs
to block angiotensin, reduce its formation,
to lower blood pressure.
But it happens that angiotensin is
one of the things at the very root of the inflammatory process.
And the inflammation of various types
can damage, for example, the olfactory nerves.
That is a very sensitive part of the nervous system.
The Greeks considered the olfactory sense
to be--it's a pun--essential: understanding
the essence of things.
Their smell is an intrinsic way of grasping
their real being, which chemists for many years
have known that they can analyze chemicals
by their nose better than machines
had been able to until just a few years ago.
So the olfactory system fails under many different kinds
of stress or aging or poisoning.
But the inflammatory system is one
of the basic routes in the cell damage.
And this virus attacks as a so-called receptor.
How it causes its damage is by binding to the ACE enzyme.
ACE2 is one of the enzymes in the angiotensin blood pressure
regulating system.
But the enzyme that binds to ACE2 rather than ACE1
is the enzyme that destroys angiotensin.
The angiotensin is the mediator of inflammation
that will damage your particular type of cells.
And ACE2, by destroying angiotensin,
protects against not only high blood pressure,
but all types of inflammation that is being studied
in relation to rheumatoid arthritis, degenerative
osteoporosis, dementia, kidney and heart failure,
especially lung fibrosis.
The pulmonary arterial hypertension
is an inflammatory process in the lungs, very highly
influenced by angiotensin.
And so the lung damage caused by the virus
is caused because it's knocking out our anti-angiotensin
enzyme.
So the logical approach to treating it
is to promote, to restore, that anti-angiotensin enzyme.
And all of the common anti-inflammatory things,
including the angiotensin receptor blockers and vitamin
B1 and aspirin, and I think the T3 part of thyroid,
progesterone, and several of the angiotensin receptor blockers,
all help to increase the production of the ACE2 enzyme
that is knocked out by the virus.
The virus lowers the availability of it,
and these anti-inflammatory things
restore the anti-inflammatory enzyme.
So even if the virus is there and you
can produce more of the protective ACE2 enzyme,
then you're OK.
Well, you beat me to my next question
because I was actually going to say,
for those who are really worried about this COVID-19,
what would be some ways of prevention
but you mentioned the aspirin and the progesterone
and things like that?
What about your thoughts on methylene blue?
Because isn't methylene blue similar to this chloroquine?
Doesn't it kind of hit the same receptors?
Am I understanding that correctly?
Well, it works by keeping your nitric oxide down.
Nitric oxide is turned on by an angiotensin,
so it works in at least part of the inflammatory system.
It's a toxic system, and it also helps
to maintain mitochondrial energy production.
And the failure of energy is at the deepest level
of the inflammatory degenerative process,
so it's doing two things.
But I haven't had any feedback from people who have tried it.
I have heard a couple of weeks ago a person in Italy
said his friend was very sick in bed,
sleeping 21 hours a day and groggy but definitely very sick
and wondered what might help.
I mentioned the Chinese research on losartan,
an angiotensin receptor blocker, and the next day he said
he had rushed out and got a 50-milligram tablet of it,
gave it to his friend, and he said his friend was already
out of bed and feeling OK.
And then several days later, he wrote again
and said his friend is exuberantly healthy
and feels like he has new lungs.
Wow, that's awesome.
I would stay with vitamin D. Vitamin D
is known for quite a few years as a very reliable antiviral
anti-infective, but it also increases
this anti-inflammatory enzyme, along with progesterone,
aspirin, thiamine, and the anti-serotonin drugs.
That was the other best-documented Chinese
research.
They were using an anti-serotonin receptor
blocker called cinanserin, C-I-N-A-N-S-E-R-I-N,
and having good results, along with losartan.
Interesting.
OK, great.
I'll go into some of the listener questions.
We only had actually one about coronavirus,
and then the rest are all other questions.
But Dan asks, can you ask Dr. Peat
about the importance of white sugar and immunity
and how it works to keep us protected
against COVID and other viruses?
It has a definite anti-inflammatory effect
by keeping the T3 thyroid hormone.
You need glucose inside the liver cells or other cells
which are producing the active thyroid hormone.
And if you are under stress, you are
likely to be liberating free fatty acids from your tissues
that will tend to block the use of glucose,
and that will put you in a diabetic pro-inflammatory
condition.
And increasing your sugar intake is
one of the things that can prevent that lipolysis, keep
the fat in your tissues where it belongs,
instead of flooding the bloodstream
and blocking sugar use and so blocking
production of the active thyroid hormone.
And the thyroid T3 has a very long history
of reversing fibrosis along with progesterone.
And for example, they would produce fibrosis
in the heart of rats and then give them an extra T3
and so that they could actually reverse the heart fibrosis
by giving them a prolonged T3 treatment.
And fibrosis of the lungs is the almost consistent outcome
of a serious infection by the coronavirus.
Excellent.
As far as I have a question, too,
still regarding coronavirus, what
about the benefits of keeping carbon dioxide levels adequate,
like even doing some bag breathing during this time
just to keep that level elevated as opposed
to like a lot of oxygen?
Yeah, that's extremely important because people
have been demonstrating for years
that the stress of surgery, the inflammation,
the systemic inflammation that's produced by, for example,
operating on your gallbladder or intestine or whatever
causes inflammation in your heart and brain and lungs,
all of your organs.
By hypoventilating, giving them less turnover of air
in their lungs during the surgery,
they protect the lungs, but also the whole systemic inflammation
is reduced by keeping the carbon dioxide level higher.
And that is something that I suspect probably 95%
of hospitals are still failing to use carbogen, which
has been known since the 1930s when Yandell Henderson showed
that fire departments using oxygen for resuscitation
had consistently better results when
they use either 5% or 7% carbon dioxide added
to their oxygen tanks because the anti-inflammatory
and breath-stimulating and oxygen-delivering effect
of carbon dioxide is much better than when
you force the CO2 level down by giving them pure oxygen or even
increased oxygen to 50% or 60%, like is very typically done
in a ventilator.
That high excess of oxygen is lowering
the amount of CO2 circulating in your blood,
increasing inflammatory reactions exactly what
a person with an influenza doesn't need.
OK, I'm so glad we're talking about this.
I hope people are listening and they're paying attention.
Now, we'll jump into some just basic listener questions.
I have a gal named Sandra who has asked several here.
So we'll start with her first one.
After a terrible experience with Invisalign,
where the trays, they kind of shape her teeth,
where my trays are often coated with goop
when I pulled them out and tartar was awful,
I stopped wearing the trays and I no longer
care about moving my teeth back.
I'm left with terrible excess saliva
that seems to be thicker than normal,
and this leaves me constantly having to suck my teeth, which
is super aggravating.
It has improved slightly since I stopped wearing the trays,
but it's still bothersome.
So any help with this would be greatly appreciated.
What does she have to do for excess saliva?
Oh, sometimes a low thyroid function
will imbalance your nervous system slightly
towards the parasympathetic side, which
can produce extra saliva.
But a lot of other things could be involved.
It would be good to check for temperature and pulse rate
at waking and in the middle of the day to see
how her thyroid function is.
Yeah, she had another question, actually,
that goes right along with what you just said.
She said a recent study came out about body temperature going
down approximately 1%.
Should that be a concern?
And I actually-- I think I found the study
she might have been referencing in Scientific American,
like that human body temperatures are actually
cooling down.
What do you have to say about that?
Oh, yeah.
Writing in the 1960s, Broda Barnes
commented that he was seeing much more hypothyroidism
than he had seen when he started his studies in the 1930s.
And the typical food supply, when people ate fish or poultry
or beef or pork, they were likely to be including
some of the thyroid gland in their diet.
Beef and pork thyroids were thrown into the sausages.
And the chicken necks and fish heads
were always used in the soup.
But starting around 1942, the US Department of Agriculture
ordered meat producers to remove the thyroid gland
from the meat sold to the public and to either put it
in dog food or sell it to the pharmaceutical companies
to make pills with.
So starting in the 1940s, people were no longer
eating their normal diet if they were omnivores.
They were continuing to eat anti-thyroid foods
without the balancing actual supplement of thyroid tissue
in their diet.
And at the same time, the increased use
of liquid oils as shortening instead of lard and butter,
people were propagandized as to add corn oil, soy oil,
safflower, seed oil, and later canola, and so on.
The reason for that was that these were otherwise
waste by-products, or they were used in the paint industry.
And the paint industry no longer had the need for them.
So they propagandized the public to believe
that they were health foods, and those
are the most powerful anti-thyroid
pro-estrogenic food additives that we're exposed to.
And their known effect is to lower the metabolic rate
and therefore the resting temperature.
Yeah, this body temperature thing I looked up
said something about because of even the clothing that we wear
and the way we live more of a sedentary life
that it's slowing down our body temperature, or lowering
our body temperature as well.
The muscle activity changes our hormone balance
when the muscles are inactive, our balance
between cortisol, glucocorticoids,
and the androgens such as DHEA and testosterone
shifts in the direction of these stress hormones,
further weakening our muscles and blocking our good metabolism
based on thyroid.
So her next question is, electric cars.
Any danger from driving around in them all day
in Dr. Peat's opinion?
There were studies of people who worked in the clothing industry
and operated an electric sewing machine
for their whole career.
And they had several times the normal incidence
of Alzheimer's disease after years
of sitting at an electric sewing machine.
And I imagine an electric car has fields at least as strong
as an electric sewing machine.
Oh, for sure.
I mean, I think some of the new cars coming out
are going to be 5G compatible, too.
So then you've got 5G on top of just the electric car itself,
so--
You know, in 1968, I had been reading
about the influence of electromagnetic fields
on the nervous system.
I hadn't started graduate school yet,
but I had been studying that for years.
And a man in Moscow had been doing the best research
on that, so I went there to talk to him in the summer of '68.
And he gave me a very good bibliography
on the effects of electromagnetic fields
on both the nervous system and the gonads.
He found that those were the most likely to be damaged
by otherwise invisible and seemingly harmless
electromagnetic fields.
Yeah, not something you want to mess with.
You don't want to mess with the gonads.
OK, the next question.
About coffee, does quality matter?
Does decaf have any issues, or is it just as beneficial?
Oh, there is still some good stuff in decaffeinated coffee.
But I think the main value of coffee is the caffeine.
When black tea and coffee have been compared,
it turned out to be the caffeine that made them equally
valuable.
Before the liquid carbon dioxide method
had been used for removing the caffeine,
they were using toxic solvents.
And so some of the older studies showed a positively dangerous
effect of decaf.
But about 15 or 20 years ago, all of the standard decaffeinated
coffees were using the safer carbon dioxide method.
And as far as the-- you still get the magnesium benefits
in decaf as well, correct?
Yeah, the magnesium, some of the vitamins and anti-inflammatory
things like chlorogenic acid are still in the decaf.
You've got to love our coffee, that's for sure.
OK, so her last question here.
Can you explain what causes and possible remedy
for lipedema?
Such a sad thing to deal with for a lot of people.
I guess she has a friend with lipedema.
And this is becoming more prevalent.
Referring to the--
Or lipedema, I might be saying it wrong.
But lipedema--
Well, triglycerides, or cholesterol, or both,
or all of those.
Yeah, both in general.
When I looked it up, I noticed that in a lot
of different cases, it was becoming more prevalent.
The cholesterol directly corresponds
to your metabolic rate.
And so, inversely, proportional to your thyroid hormone
activity, the cholesterol level goes up with your TSH
as your metabolic rate goes down.
And so I've seen people lower their cholesterol level
from the 400s down to the normal range in as little as a week
by supplementing T3 carefully.
But that's been known for 80 years
that you can predictably, controllably normalize
your cholesterol.
And that usually takes care of the triglycerides.
But if the triglycerides are associated
with a diet that isn't heavy on the polyunsaturated fats,
the triglyceride itself isn't harmful and, in fact, it's better
than free fatty acids.
When you're converting free fatty acids to triglycerides,
that's a defensive reaction.
And the triglycerides in themselves
don't hurt your heart, and they're
valuable as a sign that you're under stress for some reason.
Anything you do to lower your stress
can lower the triglycerides.
So for those who don't know, lipedema
is a disorder where there is the enlargement of both legs.
You gain fatty deposits under the skin.
And a lot of people say that's not known why.
There's no understanding of what the mechanism is behind it.
But do you have an idea of what that mechanism is?
I mean, is it a cholesterol and a triglyceride or a fatty acid
issue, or is there something that's causing it
that the person is doing?
When you get the lumps under your skin,
I think that's primarily the triglycerides that
associate with that.
But I've seen people correcting their thyroid function
who got rid of their under-the-skin lumps.
OK, good.
Yeah, that's something they should look into.
And even if the blood tests don't reveal that there's
anything wrong, even if symptoms show up,
I'm of the impression that if you
have all of the symptoms of hypothyroidism or a body
issue like that going on, where obviously there's
something going on with the thyroid,
you definitely would benefit, regardless
of what the blood work says, to take some natural,
desiccated thyroid.
Would you agree?
Yeah, Broda Barnes' books are the best science
on the issue that's available without doing
a lot of searching in the literature.
The medical profession has been indoctrinated now for 50 years
to believe that they should pay attention to the TSH, Thyroid
Stimulating Hormone, as the only basis for diagnosing
hypo- or hyperthyroidism.
But they neglect the fact that stress hormones can
change the TSH level, unless you measure all of the stress-related
hormones, as well as some of the physiological indicators,
such as nerve conduction.
The TSH itself can't be meaningfully interpreted.
People can have hypothyroidism functionally
with high cholesterol, blood sugar regulation problems,
easy infections, and so on, and still
have low TSH if they're heavily under stress,
because the stress hormones will interfere and artificially
lower the TSH, making it look like you
have too much thyroid hormone when you don't have enough.
It's interesting because doctors are usually
so quick to put people on medication,
except for thyroid medication.
They always have this big range that you can fit in
so that you don't have to take thyroid medication.
And that's interesting to me, because it's almost
as if the medical system might know how powerful thyroid
medication is, that they don't want to give it to them,
because it may get rid of all the other symptoms
that they're putting them on medications for.
Yeah, that's a conspiracy theory,
that if you look at the facts, it's hard to think otherwise.
Because the fact is that almost any bad condition
can respond to the correcting supplementing the thyroid
hormone if your diet is supportive.
You have to take the diet and the thyroid into account,
and then you can--
hypertension, for example.
I have about 20 articles demonstrating curing
hypertension just by supplementing thyroid hormone.
I'm so glad you said the part, too, about thyroid and diet.
Yes, it's very important that they not just supplement
with the medication, but also work
on a better PUFA-free and anti-inflammatory diet as well.
Yeah, and vitamin D works very closely with thyroid.
And vitamin D doesn't work properly
if you're getting too much phosphate in your diet
and not enough calcium.
Karen asks, what are Dr. Peat's thoughts on dosages
of 50 milligrams of progesterone?
Is that too high, or can it be beneficial when
dealing with excess adrenaline?
During the luteal phase from ovulation to menstruation of 30
to 40 or 50 milligrams, it is a very physiological range dose.
But therapeutically, sometimes a woman
will benefit from much bigger doses
and sometimes a much smaller dose is all that's needed.
Another common medical misunderstanding
is that if you supplement a hormone,
you're going to turn off your body's ability to produce it.
That's true of the cortisol.
But you can shrink your adrenal glands
by supplementing prednisone or cortisol.
But in the case of progesterone, if you are feeding blood supply
to an ovary, for example, measuring
how much progesterone is synthesizing,
and then you add progesterone to the mix,
it stimulates the ovary's ability
to produce progesterone.
So it becomes more active.
The more progesterone is given, no one
knows exactly what the limits are.
But there's a positive feedback relationship.
So an example, the most vivid thing that I've seen
was a woman who, since puberty--
and she was 30 at that date--
since puberty, her skin had been just as white as skin can
possibly be.
And her lips, however, were purple without any makeup on.
She had a very weird appearance, like a porcelain doll
sort of with painted purple lips.
And we had been talking one afternoon about progesterone.
And I gave her a blob, probably contained maybe
50 or 100 milligrams of progesterone,
but put it on the back of her hand.
So she was only absorbing maybe 5 or 10 milligrams
into her bloodstream.
And she did that just as she was leaving.
And a few hours later, she said as she was leaving my driveway,
she felt something odd happening.
And when she got home, she looked in the mirror.
And she said, for the first time since she was 13 years old,
she had had a normal looking face, no longer purple lips,
but pink cheeks and a good pink color to her skin.
And a couple of weeks, or a few weeks after that,
she went home to visit her parents.
She said, as she came off the plane,
they both exclaimed on her appearance.
They said they hadn't seen her looking
like that since she was 13.
So one dose can profoundly normalize the adrenals,
other things being adequate.
So the next question is interesting too.
Speaking of the skin or topical, Janine
asks, it's my understanding that endocrine hormones are also
made in the skin.
Which hormones and how can we improve them?
Is that accurate in saying that there
are certain endocrine hormones made in the skin?
Yeah, in 1960, someone was studying tonsils
and found that insulin could be identified in the tonsils.
And people just hadn't been looking.
They didn't expect endocrine functions in different organs.
But it turns out that the skin even
can produce the pituitary hormones that
activate the production of things
such as cortisol, androgens, progesterone.
The skin is possibly our biggest steroid-producing organ.
But it's almost always ignored.
The brain is another major steroid-producing organ.
But it isn't generally considered an endocrine gland.
But the various protein and peptide hormones
are at least potentially produced in tissues like the skin.
Victoria asks, what could cause a cyst in the kidneys,
and how would you recommend getting rid of it?
Various hormone imbalances can do that.
Getting off polyunsaturated fats in the diet
would be one important thing.
Making sure your thyroid function is good,
that your vitamin D level is at least
in the middle of the range, and that your calcium phosphate
ratio is good.
Low thyroid is known to be able to produce fluid accumulations
in just about any part of the body, including the kidneys.
But here and there in joints, around the heart,
a lot of inconvenient places.
So it's good to consider the possibilities of diet
and hormones.
One last question.
This one's kind of detailed.
So we'll just do our best with it.
Anne has a question about her health in general.
So she has severe fatigue, anxiety, and panic.
She was diagnosed with PCOS at a young age.
And then it caught up with her in her 30s.
She went through stress, it said.
She's been following your way of eating, no PUFAs,
and following kind of a peat diet, she says.
Taking about a grain and a half of thyroid, progesterone,
magnesium, vitamin E, and still having anxiety and fatigue,
especially in the morning.
And then she has blood work that says-- oh, go ahead.
Does she mention vitamin D and calcium?
Yeah, I was going to read her labs to you.
She said she's got a prolactin of 9.7.
Her DHEA is 422.
And her cholesterol is 218.
And her vitamin D is 26.
And her CO2 is 22.
Which obviously we can see there's some problems.
So, any suggestions, she said, on her situation?
Definitely vitamin D. You mentioned PCOS.
Yeah, she started out at a young age with PCOS.
Vitamin D came to my mind when you mentioned that.
Because it and thyroid are behind the PCOS problem.
Vitamin D should be at least 50, I think, maybe 55 or 60.
And the calcium intake should be close to, if possible,
two liters of milk per day will give a protective amount
of calcium.
The vitamin D and calcium alone might
improve the sensitivity to both progesterone and thyroid.
So I would normalize the vitamin D first.
And then watch what's happening to temperature and pulse rate
and sensitivity to progesterone.
You should be able to feel the effect of progesterone
when you need it as relief within 5 or 10 or 15 minutes.
And so you can repeat the dose if you don't feel the relief.
So I am so thankful that we were able to do this.
I think this has been really enlightening
in many different ways.
And especially, hopefully, people
have a different spin on the coronavirus.
And obviously, I'm kind of a conspiracy theorist,
so that's why I had to ask some of the questions.
I think it would be good for everyone
to look at the videos by Wolfgang Wodarg, W-O-D-A-R-G,
and Sucharit Bhakdi, B-H-A-K-D-I. And John Ioannidis
has a website discussing it.
And for the people who like conspiracy theories,
there is a very good one by David Icke, spelled I-C-K-E.
I will put-- let's see if I can find those and pop them
in the show notes, too.
So that's awesome.
OK, well, I'm so thankful that we got to do this,
because I needed some Dr. Peat insight on this COVID-19,
and I feel like I've gotten it.
So thank you so much, and it's always a pleasure.
So how can people support you with your newsletter?
Can you enlighten them as to how to do that?
Because they're definitely going to want
to read what you have to say.
I'm enjoying them, anyway.
OK, I don't have anything on my website yet about the virus.
I'll be doing a newsletter on it in a couple of months, maybe.
And the place to subscribe to the newsletter
is raypeatsnewsletter@gmail.com.
And other topics are on my website, raypeat.com.
OK, I'll pop that in the show notes, too.
Dr. Peat, thank you so much.
This is awesome as usual, and we'll
be in touch for the next one.
OK, very good.
Thank you.
I've got a promo code for you.